all right welcome everybody we are
standing by just 20 minutes from now 20
to 80 minutes from now as it usually is
for a press briefing from Donald Trump's
press secretary Kayleigh McKenna and
Annie actually the best one I heard is
maggot Magon Annie she's the nanny for
Magga Trump right I kind of like that
one Donald Trump just moments ago
finished up a vaccine sort of propaganda
press conference in the Rose Garden I'll
tell you a little bit about that but I
want to go directly today to YouTube
super chats as we welcome people in and
then I have a bunch of clips to play for
you I have all sorts of different things
Keith Macomber says his immigration good
for the economy on net my answer is yes
it is Walker Anderson says Joe Biden
didn't by the way I have a 20-minute
video about that on my youtube channel
where I go into that in detail
Walker Anderson says Joe Biden denied
knowledge that any Obama officials
unmasked Flynn he personally requested
to and unmask Flynn is he so much better
than Trump the first part I'm not
familiar with at this point I would have
to research that I don't know that what
you're saying is true and yes Joe Biden
is dramatically better than Trump
dramatically Kevin Macomber also adds
menthol cigarettes were banned in
Massachusetts what are your thoughts no
idea have never smoked a cigarette can't
stand cigarette smoke and don't know why
menthol would be singled out but maybe
because there's something in it that's
even worse than normal cigarettes I
don't know
Walker Anderson says try holding the
same standard that Trump has worst
response in the world on Rogen see how
you hold up you only report from from a
negative angle no Trump did like three
things during his presidency that I
thought were reasonable and I reported
on it and I would not say that Trump has
had the worst response it is one of the
worst responses South Korea and the US
had their first cases on the same day
and just compare the two countries it's
certainly conceivable that China had a
worse response remember it started in
China China has way more people than us
and by every reasonable measure we have
more cases than they do that certainly
makes you wonder but
certainly it's possible China did worse
than the u.s. Brazil is in a disastrous
situation in fact we can pull up the
numbers right now let's take a look at
so where is Brazil here's Brazil Brazil
was later getting started but this is an
ugly ugly curve
they are dramatically getting worse so
Brazil's response may be worse than the
u.s. Russia's having real problems if
you look at the Russian curve maybe
Russia is worse than the US maybe not
it's hard to tell and then India would
be the other place that maybe has had a
worse response than the US but certainly
the the US has been in the worst 5
responses March 5th we at 221 cases
would have been a completely reasonable
moment for Trump to say hey 50 governors
I need your help we've got to do 60 days
of stay at home let's let's beat this
thing an FDR like speech where he says
this will be difficult this will be a
challenge there will be economic
problems but trust me in 60 days if we
all do this we are going to be much much
better off he didn't do it and we are
where we are today with places like you
know Texas Texas is just disastrous
another 1,300 cases yesterday growing
hotspots Florida we you know so I I
don't
I'm not saying Trump had the worst
response but it's certainly in the worst
five and the worst five I would say and
I would gladly what I mean what what do
you think's going to happen if I say
that to Joe Rogan something horrible is
gonna happen Joe rogue is gonna say no
no we were better than this country that
country there I mean listen dude the
facts are what they are okay Donna
William says did you see the video of
Kelly before she worked for [ __ ]
entertainment calling Trump a racist
Kayla you mean yes we covered that on
the program earlier this week and
Richard barb says hey David what is the
best way to reach your team a Casey area
church won a lawsuit to reopen and we
would like your take what are your thing
Thanks
you know it we get thousands and
thousands and thousands of contacts per
day so it is tough we're not able to
respond but you can always submit
stories through our website contact form
I can probably tell you because of
what's going on
that would we probably would not cover
that story next week next week is
already almost almost full Ken Clive
says my home country of India is
suffering I live in California most
people are day laborers and are
literally going hungry wish I could do
more than just donate yep
like I said Ken you know when when I say
the US had one of the worst responses we
really won't know for a little while
whose was the worst until you see the
total curves mortality rates etc but
India Brazil Russia US China maybe Iran
you know these these are the worst six
probably and we could we could debate
about exactly who is who is on that list
Carmen Edwards says since Mitch
McConnell apologized about lying don't
you think this is the beginning of
Republicans admitting their wrongdoings
just hoping now Mitch McConnell had no
choice but to correct that I mean the
McConnell said that the Obama
administration didn't leave behind a
playbook for pandemics and the Obama
administration literally left behind a
color-coded 69 page playbook
so McConnell essentially had no choice
but to uh but to take that back okay as
the super chats continue to come in let
me just go over a few things with you
the global number of official cases is
now about four and a half million with
three hundred and six thousand deaths in
all likelihood this death number is
moderately under Counting the real death
number here in the United States we are
now likely to hit 1.5 million confirmed
cases maybe today but probably more
likely tomorrow the way the numbers have
been going and we are at 87 almost
88,000 deaths we will be very very soon
we will be at 90 and then subsequently a
hundred thousand and it is absolutely
horrible we are seeing that increasingly
I should be looking at yesterday where
we have complete numbers increasingly so
we still have the early hot spots which
have a lot of cases but typically the
numbers are on the decline we also have
new hot spots in places like Texas and
Virginia Louisiana and Pennsylvania were
pretty early but Florida is increasingly
a spot North Carolina has case
is growing at a relatively rapid clip
Ohio which early was actually pretty
solid is now starting to see more and
more cases so we'll see where we are in
another 10 days some good news on
testing over the last let's see 1 2 3 4
ok the last four days in a row we've
been over 300,000 tests a day remember
we need to get to a million at a minimum
we need to get to 500,000 it's been two
and a half months we are still not there
it's embarrassing but at least we're now
with a 3 in front of it and then
hopefully next week we can go to 400,000
tests a day etc I think just here in
Massachusetts by next month we will be
testing 45 thousand a day it's like if
that's one of 50 states you know we've
got to be able to do this thing let me
say thanks to some people over on Twitch
straigh o has subscribed with twitch
prime I appreciate that
and KSD 316 also subscribed with twitch
prime also want to say thank you to oh
this is gonna be difficult rax me goon
who has signed up at join pakman.com and
is new member number one today on my
website a couple of other super chats as
we wait for Kaylee Magon Annie cynical
insomniac says what site is it that
you're using most I find say the u.s. is
ninth in the world in testing so I'm
confused no there's a bunch of websites
where they only list 20 countries and
they say among these 20 the US is number
9 but you you really have to look at all
of the data this is world ah meters dot
info all the data is there you can sort
by testing per capita and you can see
that the United States is currently 39th
in testing per capita the numbers are
there we are right ahead of Czech
Republic and Canada and right behind
Slovenia Belarus the UK and Germany so
that's the full data telling us that the
u.s. is ninth when you're only looking
at 20 countries it's not particularly
useful Walker Anderson says you make a
fair point from could have acted quicker
I would urge you to remember our
federalist system and look to local
leadership before
executive now that's that's [ __ ]
listen we we they even say right what's
that stupid phrase they say federally
guided state supported and locally
administered you know whatever it is
come on guys there are many there are
many countries that have provinces that
have States so every configuration of
government has examples that did better
than the United States and blaming
states rights for why the disaster why
why it does you know where the response
was disastrous we just don't even - many
people are dying Walker to be dealing
with that kind of kind of nonsense Kevin
Macomber says which gun laws do you
support you'd have to give me some
examples I mean there are you know
thousands of gun laws across all of the
states when it comes to gun availability
background checks reporting you'd have
to ask me more specifically a Brendon
back Beckett says Turkmenistan probably
had the worst response that maybe I
don't know enough about it to say for
sure and Charlie says many people are
saying that you should powerfully smash
the like button absolutely if you were
joining us on YouTube welcome and
absolutely smash and destroy the like
button you can even double fist like and
subscribe I think that that's even
better okay a couple of other things I
wanted to talk about a few bits of good
news today one is that there's a new
study T cells found in coronavirus
patients bode well for long-term
immunity there has been a lot of rumor
circulating about people are getting
reinfected recovering from the virus
gives you no immunity and we suspected
this wasn't the case from day one
because that's not typically how corona
viruses and viruses in general work once
you fight the virus off you have
immunity the question is for how long
and there were reports of reinfection in
South Korea and in other places there's
been nothing peer-reviewed that confirms
rapid reinfection what we found in South
Korea and in other places claiming
reinfection so far has been people who
had a false negative but were still
infected
later when they tested positive again
they really were never negative or
people who successfully cleared the
virus and had a false positive and some
cases where people got non Korona they
had coronavirus and fought it off and
then they got a different virus that was
not coronavirus and it was a presumptive
reinfection when it really was not the
suspicion was you you do have immunity
and now there is new reporting from
science about t-cells and how this is
not proof but it is certainly
encouraging that once you recover from
coronavirus you do have immunity and
that's a really important thing the
question is for how long for how long do
you have that immunity also two
questions around what's called
convalescent plasma Trump son sometimes
calls it plasma what we're talking about
is transfusing antibodies in plasma from
people who have recovered into people
who are currently sick there's two
questions is it safe and does it work
question one is is it safe early safety
indicators of kovat nineteen
convalescent plasma in five thousand
patients found I don't know if the
summary is here ah given the deadly
nature of COBIT 19 and the large
population of critically ill patients
included in these analyses the mortality
rate does not appear excessive when you
give people convalescent plasma these
early indicators suggest that
transfusion of convalescent plasma is
safe in hospitalized patients with kovat
19:00 that's important because we want
it to be safe then the question is does
it work and there are a number of new
reports including this one from Hong
Kong that showed that current patients
viral load is dramatically lowered after
receiving antibody rich liquid but that
they are having trouble in Hong Kong
procuring a donated plasma so this is
really good you know Trump's talking
about we're gonna have a vaccine by
December or maybe we're not Trump
talking about hydroxy chloroquine as he
says it or you know rum reservoir we
know it has room des vir these things
all have you know value in exploring but
increasingly it looks like the antibody
transfusions are potential
both very safe and potentially very very
effective so that is all extremely good
news in a you know a time where we're
used to just getting regular bad news
from all sorts of places we do have a
hype train happening over on Twitch I
want to say thank you to hack fuey who
says let's make Trump a one-term
president Texas david has also
subscribed and a tiny car is a new
twitch prime subscriber very much
appreciate it over on YouTube I do have
some other super chats that are coming
in Mart Fillion sends a super chat
Kevin Macomber says do you support
banning certain guns or just reg yeah
there there are certain weapons that the
average person just doesn't need
shoulder-mounted RPGs you know there's
these arguments that a lot of absolutist
like to make that listen anything just
there's no be no ban on any particular
guns once you concede that there's
anything that there should be a
restriction on urine gray area and then
then it's just a matter of where you
where you draw the line and yes I do
support banning certain weapons although
I don't believe that that is a
comprehensive solution Marc Fillion says
I am wondering why nobody talks about
the number of people who recovered well
I help tell me what you would like to
have said about that we know most people
recover and I guess I think that when
you're talking about the death rate
you're implicitly talking about people
who recover as well
Walker Anderson says blaming local
failures isn't nonsense Cuomo said there
is no human to human transmission New
York became the epicenter in the United
States not all Trump I absolutely
concede the problem we have in this
country with coronavirus is not
exclusively the fault of Donald Trump
you're completely right on t picker
Renan says Trump attacking Obama for his
reaction to h1n1 is the most Orwellian
thing I've heard in a while
yeah it's uh it's it's you know
weaponized lethal ignorant weaponized
lethal ignorant is what I would call it
a couple of other quick things Donald
Trump earlier today Oh we'll get to that
Donald Trump earlier today had a
briefing you will know
doctor foul she was wearing a mask
everybody wearing masks but not Trump
here is Donald Trump hilariously there
were there were truckers protesting
laying on the horn by the white house
and Trump could not hear Caylee Caitlyn
Collins from CNN asked her to take off
her mask it was just a complete and
total mess it's a comedy of errors
[Music]
or a partially approve magazine with
emergency news no we're looking for a
full vaccine and then later Trump is
insisting that the trucker's are
protesting in favor of Trump can you
imagine let's go to the White House and
bring our complaints to the White House
but not because we're we're gonna
protest in favor of Trump at the White
listen to this explanation from Trump
it's equipment and you hear that outside
that beautiful sound those are truckers
that are with us all the way they're
protesting in favor of President Trump
as opposed to against his hundreds of
trucks out there and that's the sign of
love right the sign of your typical
protest so I want to thank this protest
is different every other protest you go
to what you are protesting against here
the protesters showed up to protest in
favor of Donald Trump okay great
truckers they like me and I like them
we're working on something together yep
but we have the mightiest men they'll be
helping us with this by the way speaking
of truckers yep they're gonna be big
with the vaccine I mean I guess they
will be shipping the vaccine and that I
love truckers but you know Trump
seemingly a little confused about about
what's going on there let's see if we
have any sense of when this might all
get started today I guess we don't
really know let's see if c-span has any
feed going at this point in time that we
might be able to jump on not yet if at
any point any network goes live in the
room oh it looks like it may have been
pushed back an additional half hour
that's not clear but we will soon know
about that okay let me say thank you to
a lack for subscribing with twitch prime
I also want to say thank you to Nolan
for subscribing at Tier one overrun
trick twitch which I very very much
appreciate super chats continue to come
in if you want to if you're watching on
YouTube and you would like me to address
a question or comment from you and it'll
pop up in the lower left of the screen
you can submit it via super chat on
YouTube let's see here Mart billion on a
whole lot I skipped somebody Brendon
Beckett says Turkmenistan banned
mentioning the virus at all okay I don't
know anything about that but if that's
true that's wild Mart Fillion says it
would put a more positive angle to the
story
oh talking about recoveries would do all
this and I don't know that we need to
make coronavirus an artificially
positive story it's it's pretty damn
negative madeline welsh sends a super
chap Lance Smith says did you hear Elon
Musk tell drogon that they are crediting
unrelated deaths to kovat 19 for example
getting hit by a bus as a kovat 19 death
according to musk and he was not kidding
I've seen no evidence of that whatsoever
but I'm willing to have my mind changed
nor Ibaka says no matter the death
counts Trump's lemmings will follow him
off the China's fault cliff he'll never
take responsibility as it reveals his
inadequacy oh yeah listen Trump is not
going to take any responsibility for
anything up through and including after
the November election our our goal is to
remove Trump in November and let him
continue to deny responsibility as he
has three months to be a lame duck
before he leaves the White House and
then an adult can take over what else
can we never going to admit that he's to
blame for anything and there's not much
we can we can do about that
that that's just what Trump will never
ever ever ever ever take responsibility
period speaking of November a friend of
the show bill scher recently talked
tweeted about Real Clear Politics Biden
leads in some important states now he
let me explain why this is so important
this really weird CNN poll came out
recently which I found very very
misleading and what the CNN poll said
was overall in a bunch of different
toss-up states Trump is ahead by think
it was seven I don't have the poll in
front of me but it was something like if
you combine all of these states now
what's crazy is these are states with
different populations if you combine all
of them Trump's ahead by seven in all of
these states like well how's the math
being done on that when you looked in
more detail at this same poll it was a
poll of like 600 people across a bunch
of different states with different
populations and the mathematical
analyses I saw
say that there is no way that you can
take 600 people across like seven states
or six states and weighed it in a way
that it tells you anything about who's
going to win individual states so what
bill scher did is he pulled the
individual numbers state-by-state
because it's like if you add up all the
populations of six states and say Trump
is winning the popular vote in all of
these states together we have an
electoral college system what matters is
who wins Pennsylvania who wins Michigan
so what we see if you look at each state
one by one is that Biden's lead in
Pennsylvania is six and a half the lead
in Michigan is five and a half the lead
in Arizona is four point four the lead
in Florida is three point three the lead
in Wisconsin's two point seven and and
Biden is losing by one in North Carolina
these states have different populations
so if I just like mash it all together
with a few voters from each state it's a
worthless analysis quite frankly now
does this mean that Biden is going to
win these states or oh of course not of
course not but the point is this poll
that the right is just bragging about
Trump winning by seven in these six
states it doesn't even pass the sniff
test for how we do polling it doesn't
make any sense whatsoever
along these lines if we look at Real
Clear Politics just the latest polls
there are some very interesting signals
here one is Biden plus six in Florida
now listen I don't know anything about
Florida Atlantic University polls and I
don't care about Florida Atlantic
University polls this is just one poll
and in on average Biden's up three in
Florida what I do know is if Biden wins
by three full points in Florida or or
four or five or six it's over in
November I mean there is it there is
almost no path to victory for Trump if
Biden wins by six in Florida do I think
Biden's gonna win by six in Florida no I
don't know I don't but the fact that
there's even a poll saying that right
now is certainly interesting in North
Carolina Trump is now plus three there's
been a lot of people talking about Biden
could win North Carolina I would find
that difficult I would find it very
difficult for Biden to win North
Carolina I think it will go to Trump you
also see
that tillis the incumbent senator is now
back up by one there and we are going to
be watching that race very closely
because if Democrats are going to take
control of the Senate North Carolina is
going to be an important part the
gubernatorial race you have the Democrat
up 15 in North Carolina New Jersey no
surprise Biden is up very very big cNN
has Biden plus five nationally Biden
plus four an economist you gov Wisconsin
has Biden up three Ohio from Emerson
says Trump is up three Texas has Trump
up six California has Biden up thirty
and no surprise here in Massachusetts
Biden up 34 or 28 depending on which
poll you look at so increasingly
interesting data and listen we you know
people can come to me with the well
where did our fox news feed go oh here
it is I almost lost it people can come
to me with the 2016 polls were wrong and
again I would say the 2016 polls were
right that the national poll said
Hillary would win by three I think she
won by what was it two point six or
something two point four that the
national polls were right of course it
doesn't matter you need to win electoral
e and so I don't have any particular
distrust of the polls you've got to
include good polls in your sample take
an average it will give you a pretty
good idea but it is just too early to
know who's actually going to get out and
vote if you look at my interview from a
few weeks ago with Rachel Bitto Kaufer
she has a perspective she's a political
scientist that it's less about
individual voters saying I'm going to go
out and vote for Biden or go out and
vote for Trump it's more about do people
already on the Left go vote at all do
people already on the right go vote at
all that makes sense to me as a sort of
general perspective let me say thank you
to Hayden Bear
Hayden Baer is today's second new member
at join pakman.com very much appreciate
it also big thank you to she's a lion
dog for the support over on Twitch all
right let's get to some super chats I've
missed a few as they've been coming in
but let me scroll back up let's see here
okay Kevin mccomber says should we
ban ar-15 and why yeah I mean listen it
should probably be banned I don't
pretend that that's the solution to the
gun violence problem the overwhelming
number of gun homicides are happening
with handguns but if you ask me
is there a real reason why individuals
need ar-15 style rifles I don't believe
so I don't I don't believe so
but it just if you say my policy for
guns is we ban ar-15 so you're not
dealing with a whole bunch of different
issues
marika says could you talk about Biden's
foreign policy on your show yes so we
did Biden versus Trump on economics
health care and what else to end we did
one other this week I'm planning to do
foreign policy next week
Jacob Ratner says if Joe Biden wins what
are the chances Trump refuses to leave
or cause the election rigged and incites
violence so these are three different
questions if Joe Biden wins what are the
chances Trump says it was rigged very
high very very high what are the chances
Trump incites violence I think it will
result in violence from trumpets but
Trump won't openly incite it and number
three what are the odds Trump refuses to
leave he will not succeed in refusing to
leave but I think people can put that
out of their minds Trump will leave if
he loses John Koerner says Rogan is
making fun of guys wearing masks in
their car daily why would he care so
much agree with David Fromm that masks
symbolized Trump's failure so yeah the
mask has become political I actually I
know that the argument about masks and
cars is if you were out somewhere and
you picked up vegetables which somebody
else may have touched or whatever and
then you get in the car and you pull the
mask off that's when you might put the
germs from someone else's hands touching
avocados into your mouth and then what's
the point so why not just leave it on I
my I take my mask off when I get in the
car and then I immediately sanitize I
have hand sanitizer in my car I think
that it's I don't care about people
wearing masks in their cars it's
perfectly fine it doesn't bother me I'm
not doing it I think that if we had
people who just behaved more normally
we wouldn't need to be talking about
masks outside outdoor transmission is
almost zero but I get why you have
governor saying you might want to wear a
mask outside also if you can't stay away
from people because people are just
idiots essentially and don't understand
what a high likelihood or low likelihood
contagion situation is but from what
report I read I'm going from memory so
don't hold me to the exact numbers
something like 90% of contagion is
happening in at home with other people
in in your who live at home that are
that have it in indoor office spaces
public transit and large gatherings
that's 90% the other 10% is
overwhelmingly happening during periods
of time where you are indoors elsewhere
so like it could be at a grocery store
although if you're working at the
grocery store is very different than if
you're in the grocery store for 10
minutes and then almost no contagion is
happening outside now when people are
mass gathering at trail you know hiking
trails in California that obviously is a
different situation but in any case
everybody should do what what they are
comfortable with and follow the
guidelines masks in the car I don't care
about doesn't bother me if people wear
them qumola reichert says I'm confused
on the time Trump said today they were
working on a vaccine January 11th sorry
if I missed something I I don't know I
mean it's like was he lying is there
some I have no idea I have no idea where
Trump gets that data but he lies all the
time
Carlos oh yeah I'm as confused as you
are Johnny Minogue says listening to
Trump speak lately is so nonsensical I
can't tell if it's for real or an acid
flashback yeah I can't either I can't
make heads or tails out of half of what
he says Danny Thompson says you were
very similar to my own 34 year old
politically active son he has never
taken one puff of any kind of tobacco or
weed I think I have started to
substitute your voice for his you were
easier to get a hold of oh my god
Donna Williams says doubt deaths from
car accidents that are also kovat are
being registered as Cova deaths families
would see it on the death certificate
and complain yeah it sounds bonkers to
me that someone has an asymptomatic
kovat case they get into a fatal car
accident
they're tested for Kovan test positive
and COBIT is going on the death
certificate
it just doesn't pass the sniff test if
it's going on
send me some evidence and I will revise
my my perspective let me say thank you
to Gary Thompson Gary Thompson is new
member number three today at join
pakman.com very much appreciate your
support Gary thank you if you're just
joining us on Twitter twitch YouTube or
Facebook Kaylee Megan Annie the Trump
press secretary was scheduled to do a
press briefing at the top of the hour
that was ten minutes ago it seems as
though it has been rescheduled for the
bottom of the hour 2:30 p.m. Eastern
Time we are standing by and in the
meantime if you have questions or
comments you can send them if you send
them be a super chat they'll pop up on
the bottom left of the screen that's
what you see over to my left if you're
watching on twitch at twitch.tv slash
David Pakman if you subscribed via
twitch prime or just directly your
comment or question will pop up in the
vertical blue rectangle right above my
head let's see what else is on folks
minds javi Rodriguez says wouldn't the
Democratic governor winning in North
Carolina help Biden absolutely it would
absolutely
Kevin Macomber says ar-15 our semi-auto
like every other gun and many hinting
rifles shoot a bigger round okay thank
you very much I assume you mean hunting
rifle Kevin I assume even hunting rifle
there let me see oh okay let me just
refresh if you are just joining us
Donald Trump did do a vaccine propaganda
press conference earlier and he says
that we will have hundreds of millions
of doses of vaccine by the end of this
year if that happens of course I mean
it'll be great and it won't have really
anything to do with Donald Trump there
are countless you know dozens and Dondre
different labs working on on vaccines at
this point and I hope we do have a
vaccine Trump's presentation earlier
today plagued by truckers protesting and
laying on the horns here's an example of
how that went down please
excuse me you're gonna have to remove it
you can't hear through here fully
approved vaccine for the entire
general unmarried partially approved
vaccine from
do you mean a fully approve vaccine for
everyone the full public or a partially
approved vaccine with emergency news no
we're looking for a full vaccine for it
anyway so another a complete and total
mess as you see dr. Anthony foul she
finally allowed back and wearing a mask
I don't know if he spoke during this one
I didn't I didn't watch the entire thing
and I think that we have another we had
like one or two other clips here let me
see okay oh yeah yeah yeah Trump is
still doing the it's gonna go away
either way sort of thing yeah go ahead
[Music]
we think we're going to have a vaccine
in the pretty near future and if we do
we're gonna really be a big step ahead
and if we don't we're gonna be like so
many other cases where you had a problem
come in it'll go away at some point
it'll go away it may flare up and it may
not flare up we'll have to see what
happens but if it does flare up we're
gonna put out the fire right now we'll
put it out quickly and efficiently we've
learned a lot Steve do you have a
question vaccine typically would take 12
to 18 months to develop how can you do
it in your fashion what makes you think
this will work well they started
actually I guess you heard in January
early January and they've been working
on it I've I know so many and private
companies have been working on it the
government's been working on it so we've
got the time because we put a very and
they've literally been working 24 hours
a day so we've got we've got the time
and we hope to be able to do something
by the end of the year or to understand
that there's not really an answer there
about how are you compressing the time
like I guess he's saying people are
working 24 hours a day but it's like the
real question is which step is being
skipped or compressed right because
they're they're certain you've got to
sequence the virus and then develop a
prototype vaccine and then you've got to
do safety testing often testing on on
monkeys and then you do efficacy testing
and you track people so the question
that I would like to see asked is which
phase is being shortened and really we
know the answer to that anthony foul she
has said that you what you could
potentially do is if you would normally
follow people for a year to see if the
immunity lasts a year if you know that
it's working for six months of immunity
at month seven you could say hey we're
gonna do emergency use like this one
safe and it does six months of immunity
that's good enough for us to do
emergency use and give it to health care
workers meanwhile we'll keep testing to
see if it gives a year of immunity
that's really the phase that you would
short and Trump doesn't understand this
stuff and you know not not really
getting at that detail certainly okay
other super chats coming in joke rockin
berg says slick your hair
right back let's see I mean my hair is
dry how could I possibly I mean it's
like as soon as I let go of it it Joe I
don't know if you're familiar with the
physics of semitic hair but it doesn't
really work that way
dave Wampler says how do trump cultists
reconcile him citing 2 million deaths
with no action yet themselves not
wanting to social distance it's
incoherent you're rightly pointing out
that it's incoherent Jay Harper says do
you think that doctor foul Chi wore a
mask to avoid visibly cringing at
Trump's stupidity no I don't think
that's why but I think he wore a mask
because he knows it's the right thing to
do Clayton Sackett says is Trump the
best thing that ever happened to your
career yes he's a political dumpster
fire and I've thoroughly enjoyed your
coverage of yeah you know there's a
there's all these people who write to me
and they're sort of like pissed that I'm
saying I'm gonna vote for Biden and all
this different stuff and like that I'm
shilling for the DNC or whatever listen
guys Biden becoming president would be
bad for my show right the pro these
shows do better when we are more
obviously in the in the opposition now
if Biden becomes president I'm going to
be pushing for him to actually do
progressive stuff and it'll be a
different show I think it'll be a show
that can maybe even get more
accomplished right now we're trying to
keep the resistance language together so
that we remove this guy if Biden goes in
now we've got someone that is a
potential ally and we've got to push
them to be progressive so we're gonna be
plenty busy if Biden's the president but
people who you know what what moat the
idea of an ulterior ulterior motive for
promoting Biden I'm I'm telling you that
I'm voting for Biden because he's better
for the country and it will not be as
good for my show are all programs like
mine have had their best phases during
Donald Trump because we've never seen
anything this cartoonishly weaponized
and of course Trump has been good for
for the program Gary Thompson says
nothing okay medic he man says hey David
wanted to say thanks for covering these
press briefings with your commentary
keeps me informed without going crazy
the propaganda appreciate that thank you
Andrew Dwyer says what restaurant do you
miss most in Boston oh you will so
here's the thing most Boston restaurants
are open for take-out so I've been able
to continue patronizing a lot of my my
favorite restaurants but places I've not
been for a while
mama'll is delicatessen in Cambridge I
haven't been to for a while what other
places do i I mean there's just so many
great places in in Boston Yankee lobster
company I've not been to for a while but
a lot of the places like you know Bess's
cafe and Brookline is a fantastic place
I go there there's there's just so many
noodle barn in Jamaica Plain is great
there's a bunch of great pizza and
calzone spots I mean you know the
takeout is widely available so I'm still
I'm still able to get takeout when I
want incredible TV says can't stick
around for the stream but here's a
couple bucks thank you thanks incredible
appreciate that JR says I watched your
show with Andrew Lake off and most of
your others your questions are arguably
the most intelligent asked of anyone
naive question if CNN or MSNBC said they
had to have you on their team would you
accept you know I mean listen obviously
there's a dollar amount at which it's
like hey you know there's a there's a
financial incentive at a certain point
where it's like what am i doing if I say
no but I I really like the setup that I
have which is I'm my own boss I don't
have an editor I do the stories I want
right now I'm working from home a lot of
them are as well but you know five years
ago I would have said Oh any offer from
one of those places of course that's the
dream it's not the case anymore I mean
listen is there some way that they could
lure me away from this show sure but
it's not it's not at all the dream or
the goal at this point Luke says hello
you may remember me a sensible talk had
to close that account because of verbal
abuse by never by dinners keep spreading
the truth David okay Luke I don't
remember that I apologized but but I
appreciate you being back Andrew Dwyer
says love noodle barn yeah it's a great
spot if you go to noodle barn I highly
recommend the Tom Yum entre soup Tom Yum
entre soup and I know that you know
a lot of people will say the see here's
the thing at noodle barn the all of
these entree soups including Tom Yum are
under the foie section of the menu and
as many of you know with foie typically
you get the accoutrements which include
a lime it includes a sort of spicy chili
sauce it includes sprouts as well as
Thai basil which you rip up and you
throw this stuff on now I know that you
typically don't put that stuff on a tom
yum soup I understand that it's only
with it because it's under the section
of the menu but I just throw the sprouts
on I throw that I don't care and every
time my girlfriend's like that's that's
meant for fun
that's not Metford Tommy I don't care I
love the Thai basil
I love the sprouts it's all going on my
friends it's all going on joke rockin
berg says I didn't mean right now I mean
as a style to try it out since it's so
long now how do you think this turns out
in two weeks for places like Florida oh
okay so I think Florida is gonna be in
rough shape in two weeks your point is
well-taken I actually have been slicking
my hair back now because it's so long
when I get out of the shower but by the
time it dries this is what happens and I
have to tell you I'm not totally
displeased with it I think it's working
for me at this point in time a retro
Pathak says lack of spine makes raves
stand-up routine bearable geez I have no
III get I don't a retro has been around
for years and I love his support I never
know what he's talking about
Oh rave Dubin I get it oh let me
reinterpret lack of spine makes dave
rubin stand-up routine unbearable okay
cool let's see I want to say thanks to
Robert Allard Robert Allard has just
subscribed at join pakman.com I also
want to say thanks to Jarrett Bolano
Jarrett bolaño is new member number five
today at join pakman.com gary thompson
says hey David looking forward to the
White House comedy show funny if it were
not so serious and tragic greetings from
the UK
and thanks for all your good work yeah
the UK recently has been not doing great
it looks like in terms of coronavirus oh
no actually they're doing okay for
whatever reason I thought the UK was
spiking recently let's look at deaths no
the UK they're doing better than us I
spoke too soon and I take it back
yes greetings from the UK I was in
London in December love London also went
to Oxford and it was very very enjoyable
really really I just London's great
London's right Durazo panas says please
take a look at slow killing of democracy
in Poland Constitution obstruct and
breaking it to rigor 'el MPs postpone
presidential election okay I will look
into that Michel Blanco says if Biden
wings do you think the 2024 Republican
candidate will emulate Trump's behavior
and rhetoric or will run is more of a
moderate voice I don't know the answer
to that I think there we're not going to
know I think the 2022 midterms will be a
signal as to whether 2024 will be
another trumpian candidate or some
return to something a little more sane
like oh whoa there's something weird on
the screen behind me or something a
little more sane like like Mitt Romney
for example yeah that showed up and that
I don't know oh that's because there's
some app I guess that has an update geez
that's embarrassing I'm gonna have to
deal with that later there's really no
way let me see if I can lean over and
deal with that it's going from that bad
to worse all right let me let me deal
with that real quick hold on it's it's
actually getting getting very very ugly
let's see if I can can hold give me one
second guys
you
okay very good we are back on it got my
screen got hacked how embarrassing is
that that was crazy um okay let's go
next to alex stephenson who says when
are we getting our next chess tournament
yeah I have promised the chess
tournament and we should do it soon
I would tentatively say let's see if we
can figure it out right now mmm there's
a lot going on this coming week let me
see I would potentially do it on Tuesday
night Tuesday night might work for the
chess tournament we'll see I'll keep
everybody posted we'll announce it over
the weekend if it is indeed going to
happen we should be just a few minutes
from the start of the rescheduled Kaley
Magga nanny
press briefing today Donald Trump's
latest press secretary her press
briefings have traditionally started 40
minutes late and lasted between 20 and
25 minutes often ending in a rage quit
after a nasty question is asked so we'll
see how today's goes I assume she'll
have a page about vaccines which was the
topic of Donald Trump's Rose Garden
briefing earlier today and we will we
will see how it all goes
Danny Thompson says a few extra bucks
for being able to laugh at technical
difficulties thank you
Bob Allard says David IgE unsubscribed
and Ari subscribed without the discount
thanks for all you do appreciate it Chad
lightning says favorite pizza spot I
loved Regina's when I visited I've never
been to Regina's in in Boston my
favorite pizza spots are probably so I
really like a for pizza in Cambridge
they've got tremendous pizza excellent
excellent pizza in Jamaica Plain I like
a Rizzo's and JP House of Pizza
and real-deal all have good pizza and
Jamaica Plain in Brookline I'm not sure
Brookline would but there's so many good
pizza spots in Boston there really are
joke rockin berg says I voted for Bernie
but you've talked me into voting for Joe
Biden with your video the other day I
live in Florida and have gotten others
to agree
love it Joe and to be clear I'm not
evangelizing people do anything that's
not in line with their values right what
I'm saying is if you do not want Trump
to become reelected then make sure that
your actions are in line with that and
if you'd rather say screw it I want to
punish Biden or punish the DNC or punish
America or whatever because it's not
Bernie or whatever so I actually prefer
it to be Trump hey that's great if those
are your values then vote your values I
just don't want the posturing about
people who say Trump's a disaster but
what about Tara Reid but what about
Biden being a centrist or this or that
like just own it right just say I'd
rather Trump and Biden either for their
policy perspectives or because you have
an acceleration as point of view I've
explained what that means just own it
right I I'm not gonna go out and
evangelize if those are your values then
you if you prefer Trump to Biden then
you should be acting in accordance with
that great right just do it just don't
do the posturing right just say it
straight up and I'm much more respectful
of that
Matthias Germany says isn't Trump a
result of the u.s. to party democracy
yes and I mean you'd have to say more
about in what way you mean that
Zach Bushman says where do you think the
supreme court will land on Trump's taxes
hoping they'll compel do bank to release
them but I'm not optimistic I'm like 55
they will say they've got to be released
45% they will not that's where I am
right now
and that that does not that's that's
basically like flipping a coin it's
almost like flipping a coin okay let me
say thank you over on twitch to a few
people Skiz mage has subscribed with
twitch Prime Justin D winters has
cheered and Bennett 362 has also
subscribed with twitch prime very much
appreciated let me take one minute and
one minute only to remind you that
everything we do here the daily
broadcast showed the clips the streams
the chess tournaments all all this
different stuff it's all made possible
by
people who just grab a membership on my
website okay all these other ways to
support the show they're great but all
these big companies are taking taking
taking slices off of the support when
you go to join pakman.com you get a
membership we pay only 2.9 percent to
swipe credit and debit cards we get the
rest ok it's the most direct way to
support us tragically and I do I'm not
being hyperbolic when I say this
tragically because of the virus in March
and April 722 members canceled their
paid memberships it was brutal to look
at every day every single day you know
that's that that's like 12 people a day
canceling memberships it was brutal but
I understand what's going on and we're
all in this together if you are okay
financially and you value what we do
every day all of the content consider
grabbing a membership at join pakman.com
with the coupon code right there 2020
now it's 2 bucks a month literally 2
dollars a month if you pay for the
entire year it's only $1 80 a month
dollar eighty-three something like that
and I will thank everybody who gets a
membership we're at five
our goal is 25 I think we can do it and
everybody gets a thank you from me we
used to actually have problems when I
would mention it on streem the website
would crash because the website was
underpowered but we've added the
additional elements of cloud hosting and
now the website doesn't crash when
people try to sign up it's a beautiful
thing and I I welcome all of those
signups and with peace and love we may
get to 25 new members today all right
let's see here kori keen says can you
please wish my brother Sean a happy
birthday absolutely happy birthday Sean
I hope you're having a good birthday
Carlos Alejo has sent a super chat G
Bradbury says the UK paid 20 million
pounds for hydroxychloroquine just
another Trump scam that will have
profited some of his donors no doubt
imagine the cost worldwide I don't know
about that but I'm interested in looking
into that joonie McGraw says do you
think it would be easier to bring
manufacturing jobs back to the states or
install a ubi system so
they're there they're really not they're
not related in in a one or the other way
bringing manufacturing jobs back to the
US has one set of challenges
putting in a ubi system has another set
of challenges that's mostly political
challenges and we'd have to we'd have to
think through it in a little bit of a
different way
hands urgh Reni says great show David
keep on the good work we're counting on
the sanity of the u.s. elections
greetings from Germany
listen counting on sanity from the
United States is a risk it's a risk
green lover says I want to have DnB rave
in the gardens of the White House DnB
okay
drums and drum and bass is that what
that is jay-ar says I need to add you
should also take Pat with you for the
split screen intelligent analysis
discussion afterward just in case their
ratings with soar would soar okay all
right very good I don't know exactly
what jr. is referring to there but I
love it I absolutely love it
it looks like we're getting close now to
the start of today's press briefing if
anybody is aware of a stream that is
live in the room I'm glad to switch to
it let's see if c-span is covering this
one it doesn't look like it
this is Fox and they've not yet gone
live in the room this is the White House
they are not yet live in the room let's
see if anybody else is okay I don't know
if sometimes Time magazine let's see if
Time magazine is running a live feed in
the room tends to give us an idea of how
far we are from the stream say time
press briefing I'm not seeing that time
has a feed either all right well in any
case if anybody can let me know if you
come across a live feed that's that's in
the press briefing room I will gladly
switch to it but right now I don't see
it right now I don't see yet all right
let me say thank you to a few new
subscribers this is very very exciting
hold on a second here Robert Allard we
talked about Jared Bellon oh okay Thomas
DeMaio 'la is new member number six
today thanks Thomas I also want to say
thanks to Amanda Schroeder whose new
member number seven today Carlos no guez
or no guess is new member number eight
Miriam Rivera is new member number nine
Chris white you are new member number
ten today very much appreciate that
Derrick Cunningham is new member number
eleven Austin Cleveland is new member
number twelve hunter Lambertson hey
hunter you are new member number
thirteen today very much appreciated
some of these folks using the coupon
code for 66% off some not either way
there's no pressure here there's no
shame to the coupon code there's no
pressure not to use it it's not
means-tested it's take it take the
coupon code we love it let's see here
Carlos Elias says what are your thoughts
on spaceforce
I think it is the perfect nexus of
weaponized ignorant from Donald Trump
militarism and the military industrial
complex and corporatism I think it is a
perfect blend of all of those elements
DG d FY HD says I appreciate your work
your job doesn't seem easy but you were
very good at what you do thank you I
appreciate that
Freddy Bernard says USA Today has a feed
in the room let's take a look at that
and see if we can pull it up USA Today
press briefing uh-huh there we go good
let me switch to that it's possible that
an ad will play but we'll just we'll
deal oh here we are very good okay all
right it looks like we must be pretty
close because the room is relatively
full at least as full as it gets these
days what would the limited capacity in
the room hmm
excellent let's see here David Adams
says did you see Trump's operation
warp-speed I did I mean listen I hope we
get the vaccine as soon as possible I
hope we have hundreds of millions or
billions of doses available if we do
it's not really going to be because of
anything Trump did I mean we have you
know Trump brought on our vaccines are
now understand that oh the only thing
you can do at this
point is shortened testing and approval
there are 70 vaccine candidates already
so the what I really want people to
understand is Trump now brings on a
vaccines are and now says we could have
hundreds of millions of doses by the end
of the year maybe we will maybe we won't
but the vaccines that are that are
likely to be the ones that even with
emergency use authorization z' and
shortened testing periods are going to
be the ones available at the end of the
year are ones that have been in
development already right so if it's you
know Oxford University developed that
has nothing to do with Trump Trump might
say to his FDA absolutely short-circuit
the testing and and approval phase and
just let's get it out there okay but new
vaccines that have not yet even been
been started are not going to be the
ones available at the end of the year
it's going to be the ones that are well
underway and Trump of course will take
credit for it no doubt but we have to
remember that it won't really be because
of anything he did Nick shaper has
subscribed on YouTube so has Kitty Ewing
Wagner Rock says what is the coupon code
the coupon code is right there the
coupon code is in blue text and it is
2020 now to zero to zero n o w and it
saves you 66 percent couple other people
I want to thank en Malek Ian Malek is
new member number fourteen today Billy
terraza Vick or Terrace Civic is new
member number fifteen today Vanessa
Hendricks is new member number sixteen
on my website thanks Vanessa
and Terry Holyfield is new member number
seventeen today as we are standing by
for the start of today's press briefing
thank you so much really really do
appreciate people who are appreciating
the live streams and grabbing those
memberships also want to say a quick
thank you to our kin nine for the twitch
subscription at twitch.tv slash David
Pakman very much appreciate that oh and
what else did I have here to get caught
up on I think that was it yeah
good I think we're caught up excellent I
did Oh people are asking what why didn't
I stream the Trump Fiasco earlier I
didn't stream Trump's thing earlier
because quite frankly I was just busy
and now I'm now I'm not so so now I'm
streaming let's see what other clips
Aaron had from it that was yesterday
okay so here's the big promise by the
way from mark this was the big vaccine
promise that was made well thank you mr.
president for your leadership of this
bold and historic initiative the
department defense is very excited and
committed to working closely with our
partners at HHS across the government
and in the private sector to accomplish
the mission we have begin of given
winning matters and we will deliver by
the end of this year a vaccine at scale
to treat the American people and our
partners abroad you know the department
defense has been in this fight since day
one
going back to January we've stayed ahead
of the curve very step of the way and
today obviously those are complete and
total lies but listen if publicly making
the prediction of a vaccine at scale by
the end of the year encourages them to
help get it done I'm all for it guys I
don't care who finds the vaccine as long
as it's safe and effective that's what I
care about and we I let's do it I mean
you know let's let's let's do it it
seems difficult but to guarantee
hundreds of millions of doses by the end
of the year but let's see him do it
Derek Cunningham says if capitalism is
the perfect economy for everyone versus
socialism versus communism why is it
that every 15 years US taxpayers or
government bails out corporations when
it all goes wrong that's right that's
that's a feature of unregulated
capitalism and the way or or under
regulated capitalism the way to mitigate
that is with the policies of social
democracy where there are still phases
right but they are smoothed out now
you're probably limiting the peaks a
tiny bit but the really important thing
is the damage done by the draw
cops are far more damaging than the
damage done by the peaks may not be
quite as high and that's really the the
underlying concept of social democracy
thanks to Joel Ballmer for subscribing
on YouTube that Chavez says in order to
get the true death toll amid the
pandemic should we do the math by total
population or confirmed cases can you do
a video please Thanks well so the death
rate per capita is based on the total
population so your question there's just
different metrics the case fatality rate
is the number of people died from
confirmed cases the infection fatality
rate is the percentage of people die
from the presumed total cases which
you're estimating admittedly each metric
serves a different purpose okay let me
say thank you to a very special twitch
viewer dr. dong strong dr. dong strong
very exciting subscribing with twitch I
also want to say thank you to Aidan
O'Malley whose new member number 18
today Dave Perry is new member number 19
today Joel Adams is new member number 20
mantris Kevon twizzle is new member
number 21 I love that Robert beers is
new member number 22 and I also want to
say thanks to Lance Cogan new member
number 23 and barreled the cost number
24 as we get started with the press
briefing let's go over to the White
House feed here it is a little bit
behind but I find it to be a better feed
and I think that this is going to
position us very very strongly for the
start of the press briefing let's take a
look
hello everyone sorry we're a little late
today as you know the president had two
events this morning so we didn't want
our own precedent and transparency to
get in the way of lunch so we're glad
that you all had a few moments there to
eat so our delay people to you guys I
have an announcement on the Trump
administration's unwavering support for
our farmers today Secretary of
Agriculture sonny Perdue and senior
adviser Ivanka Trump announced the
launch of their family's food box
program this is a three billion dollar
program whoa that looks provide food to
our most vulnerable communities those
your advisor Ivanka Trump and secretary
petit Perdue are doing very good work
now I would like to focus on the Trump
administration's unprecedented
coronavirus response yeah some have
erroneously suggested that the Trump
administration throughout the pandemic
response PlayBook left by the
obama-biden administration we found it
note however is that this thin packet of
paper was replaced by too detailed
robust pandemic response report
commissioned by the Trump administration
which did nothing to actually stop the
spread I'll hand over to my assistant
Wendy for these two pandemic response
plans talk about propaganda oh my god in
2018 the Trump administration issued our
pandemic crisis action plan one of the
binders that I just handed to Lyndee
further from August 13th to the 16th the
Trump administration conducted the
crimson contagion 2019 functional
exercise this was a pandemic stimulation
to test the nation's ability to respond
to a large-scale outbreak seems like we
failed in January of 2020 HHS issued the
crimson contagion 2019 functional
exercise after-action report that was
one of the additional documents that I
just handed over this exercise expounded
upon exposed rather the shortcomings and
legacy planning documents which inform
president Trump's coronavirus response
beginning as early as January in the
legacy planning document shortcomings
were in fact the papers that I just
handed over that were provided to us by
the obama-biden administration for
example President Trump
crimson after-action report highlighted
that the Obama era policy directive from
November 2016 quote and I'm quoting from
the document does not provide the
reckless and requisite mechanisms or
processes to effectively lead the
coordination of the federal government's
response instead president Trump
established the White House coronavirus
task force and put vice president which
pence in charge of the interagency
response these were effective decisions
and they undoubtedly enhanced our
response to the corona virus furthermore
what crimson contagion taught us is that
President Trump was right all along
about misguided economic and trade
policies that left Americans vulnerable
to pandemics in June 2016 so many many
years ago then businessman Donald Trump
said this quote America became the
world's dominant economy by becoming the
world's dominant producer I have visited
cities and towns across this country
where a third or even half of
manufacturing jobs have been wiped out
in the last twenty years today
we import nearly 800 billion more in
goods than we export this is not some
natural disaster it is politician made
disaster that was then candidate Trump
who has now implemented those policies
so understand that we have a trade
deficit for a reason and it's because
the country decided 25 30 years ago that
we value cheap Chinese stuff more than
domestic production you can change that
but the idea that it comes at no cost is
laughable and that's never mentioned by
these people on trade ripping up NAFTA
it was replacing it with the u.s. Mexico
Canada agreement a great deal for our
auto makers in our farmers and it was
ending China's predatory trade policies
and negotiating a historic phase one
China deal that is what this president
has done yesterday President Trump went
to Allentown Pennsylvania and visited
Owens and miner Inc this was a clear
example of domestic manufacturing at
work you saw this administration taking
action to restructure and secure our
stockpile of medical supplies President
Trump released a plan to restructure the
strategic national stockpile yesterday
and he signed an executive order
providing the authority to ensure
America is Purdue
seeing critical goods necessary to build
up our strategic stockpiles the
president's trip was an example of what
he's been saying all along that America
must manufacture that America must
produce here and of it's an example of
Trump not wearing a mask again to reject
air bridge to bring supplies from all
over the world to support America's
frontline health care workers the
administration partnered with the
private sector to secure donations and
production of PPE and other medical
supplies and president Trump effectively
leveraged the defense production Act
otherwise known as the DPA to mobilize
our country to manufacture and secure
massive amounts of PPE and ventilators
through project air bridge two dates
more than 1.4 million n95 respirators
have been delivered as well as 9900
21,000,000 glove 17.1 million surgical
gowns and more the Trump playbook and
the whole of America response to this
pandemic has far exceeded what this
administration inherited and finally
President Trump took action before the
pandemic to anticipate and gameplan such
scenarios president Trump's streamline
the National Security Council in 2018 by
creating a counter proliferation and
violence the idea that anything about
the NSC was streamlined the NSC has been
a complete and total [ __ ] show on which
at one point Steven Bannon was meeting
can you imagine Steve Bannon with the
National Security Council acquired some
experts to report to two bosses
simultaneously and short the NSC
retained the same number of experts
focused on biological threats that the
Obama administration had but honed them
in and focused them more and housed them
in a more coherent structure and with a
more senior leader I'd also note that
this Directorate which exists today is
the same office that critics alleged to
this day that President Trump eliminated
I hope in your reporting you are now
able to debunk this claim remember Trump
bragged about debunk the disbanding the
pandemic response team now she's using
semantics to talk about something
totally different
typical incidents including pandemics in
September of 2018 President Trump
released the National bio defense
strategy in May of 2019 he released the
global health security strategy and in
September of 2019 he signed an EO to
modernize influenza vaccines his
leadership is evidence in the early days
of this path
Zdenek and in the preparation before
that and these actions I've outlined
today these plans I noted helped us as
we approached what it was an
unprecedented crisis it helped us to
deploy our resources and to deliver what
I believe is the one of the best
responses we've seen in this country's
history and with that I'll take
questions oh my god
talked about crimson contagion back in
August did that exercise suggest that
early and extensive testing would be
critical in response to any pandemic I'm
not aware of exactly what it were reveal
with regard to testing wait a second so
it didn't say you need a lot of testing
or it did because either way you screwed
up previous iterations of plans have put
HHS in the lead HHS of course odd to
plays a critical role that's a great
question because if he says the Crimson
contagion did say we needed a lot of
testing well then we didn't do it
if the crimson contagion did not say we
need a lot of testing then it wasn't a
very good guide because clearly we did
need a lot of testing good question no
answer president leading this we need
the White House at the helm coordinating
agencies and that valuable piece of
advice that we garnered from from from
the exercise was able to be deployed in
real time so it was a valuable exercise
that we did in August of 2019 and going
forward well early in extensive testing
now be among the recommendations that
in future so we don't we have not
outlined a future plan just yet we're
still operating off of the one that was
issued fairly recently in January of
2020 I think it's safe to say that you
know we've learned a lot as we've moved
forward and navigated this pandemic oh
yeah and navigated the deploying of more
than 90 million and 95 respirators a
billion gloves on this really historic
response I think wait now it's a billion
glue had it wasn't that so much smaller
number yesterday incredible innovative
private sector in this country and to
have a businessman at the helm and
president Trump who was able to
coordinate that was very effective and I
think will become the playbook for
dealing with future pan no no no Caitlin
will be the playbook for school so you
replace the Obama playbook when these
two you say that you've developed is it
in there that the testing needs to be
increased as soon as this is happening
and what about personal protective
equipment well personal protective
equipment is very important and I'm
proud of what this administration has
done and I'm very glad that you asked
about let me go to my PPE stats numbers
for you today
I actually shortchanged just a little
bit there ninety two point seven million
and ninety-five mass 133 point seven
million surgical masks twenty two point
four million surgical gowns 10.5 million
face shields and almost 1 billion gloves
and as you saw it Owens and minor our
domestic manufacturing has been deployed
in this country in a way it never has
been before since at least world war two
and will become the future playbook I
believe for future administrations and
navigating a pandemic response playbook
that personal protective again creased
soon as a pandemic is underway as with
virus what it what it says is this that
look we need personal protective
equipment and what did this
administration do let me show us those
binders Kaley one of these I believe is
public one is public so you can look
through that online but what we've done
is remarkable and that is exactly what
you just asked me does it say we need
more PPE well we've delivered historic
numbers of PPE 1 billion gloves we'll
continue to do that we'll continue to
fill the stockpile we're ready for the
fall and this administration has acted
in a way that I don't believe certainly
based on what I read in the Obama
playbook would have able to have
deployed with this administration have
done Jeff so long to get more masks and
swaps and whatnot which they're still
dealing with now but the other question
is on a break right the president said
yesterday that he probably should not be
working in federal government anymore
but he is now expected to start his new
job next week does the president still
welcome him starting that new position
and can you clarify exactly what that
job is well it's interesting to ask
about whether Rick bright should start
in a position because Rick bright hasn't
showed up for a position he was
transferred as a bold new $1,000,000,000
testing program he's not yet shown up
for work he takes a two hundred eighty
five thousand dollar salary that's
extraordinary for a federal government
salary and he is still on
taxpayer-funded medical leave so he can
work with partisan attorneys to malign
this president so mr. bright he should
perhaps show up for the job that he
currently has Jeff
choose not to wear a face mask does he
think it sends the wrong message that's
his choice you know he's tested each and
every day those of us around him I'm in
the Oval Office I I wear a face mask on
around him to protect him um he's very
protected he tests negative daily and
that's his personal choice and I would
know it is consistent with the CDC
guidelines which say they recommend but
it's the personal choice of the
individual for the American people dr.
burns doctor pouchy today they're both
tested routinely but they both have yep
she's not gonna wear I think he did set
an example he set an example when he
said to the west wing I want all of you
wearing face masks in here and he said
like a week ago three days ago and that
is over above and beyond what CDC
guidelines say but all of our staffers
are wearing face masks and that was at
the direction of the president I think
that's a pretty good example yes I don't
ask you about the FDA guidance on the
tests but firstly and you know you talk
about all of this preparation that the
competent estrella did
but then how come on January 2020 the
stockpile is as low as it was on
supplies like Big Macs
yeah it's a really good question it's a
really important question perhaps I
should direct your question to President
Obama who left the stockpile and see and
there was a USA Today fact check of that
three and a half years was not enough
time to fill the empty cupboards I guess
no indication that the Obama
administration took significant steps to
replenish the supply of a 95 mass in the
strategic national stockpile after it
was depleted from repeated crises so
that the h1n1 question is what's a
reasonable amount of time for Trump to
fill it it's 3.5 years not enough did
empty and took President Trump to refill
it yeah well we refilled that stockpile
we got the 95 mass outside the last
leaders another good example not a
single American died for lack of a
ventilator a hundred thousand
ventilators that's not really three
times what is produced in the average
year three times the amount of in 95
respirators our health care industry
uses we have delivered we cleaned up the
mess that was very clearly left by
President Obama and we got that out and
I would also note in terms of fixing the
stockpile it's also fixing domestic
supply chains that was very important
and this president is the president who
took on that issue who said we need to
produce here we can't you guys think
Trump is fall for this stuff because
they love Caylee they think she's really
good means these are such transparent
lies but I think that she's effective to
the trumpets Billy to this degree took
on that systemic fix
using the test that you guys take every
day that we've started been given every
day
but these two recent studies coming up
any numbers like a third of cases may be
missed up to 48 percent of cases meeting
this does that give this White House any
pause are you considering potentially
other tests does this change the way
that you guys are gonna move forward
yeah so I'm glad you asked that it's
very important when the FDA gets any
information that calls into question a
test they put it out there it's
incumbent upon them to make sure the
American people have up-to-date
information dr. Han I spoke with him
this morning I actually spoke with him
several times he said we continue to
recommend the tests secretary a czar
says we have confidence in the tests
otherwise it wouldn't be out on the
market that being said they take any
indication of false negatives very
seriously some of these studies
secretary a czar says he believes there
was user error error in them meaning
that the time transporting them might
have affected the accuracy of the test
but to that end what the FDA has said is
that any negative test results that are
not consistent with a patient's clinical
signs so if you're coughing you get a
negative test it's a nabbit test you
should consider getting a second test
that's the guidance as of now Wow so
that test that she's using to say
trumpet and a mask may not work
he's very frustrated with China and I'll
leave it to the President as to when he
does resume speaking with the Chinese
leader but look China slow up to this
I've shared with you guys before on
human to human transmission it was
really important that the world knew of
that aspect of the disease but that
information was slow walked through the
w-h-o the genetic sequencing likewise
was not given on until a professor in
Shanghai did so on his own that's you
know why are they letting flights out of
China but not into China these decisions
put American lives at risk not just
American lives for lives around the
globe we know that this disease came
from China and why that information was
not shared some of the information I
just suggested is really unacceptable
the China stuff ignores that it came
from China for the purposes of every
country in the world in some countries
dealt with it really well and some dealt
with it very poorly well we did to the
president asked how to characterize
their relationship but you know this is
a president who if anyone knows how to
talk to China it's him he did get the
phase one China deal 250 billion dollars
of purchasing of American products is a
big deal and a big one for America and
it took President Trump to get that one
yes
I was developing a quote super-duper
missile Pentagon was asked about that
shortly after the president made his
remarks he declined to combat refrain
I'm wondering if you can say what the
president was describing yeah I would
just refer you back to the president
mark remarks in the Pentagon I don't
have any new information on that
basically yes start replenishing the
stockpile of PPE beauty and does that
report get into that um the president
immediately when it was necessary to get
more PPE for America's health care
workers immediately went into action so
understand I she sang the cupboards were
bare on January whatever 2017 but only
when workers needed it for the virus did
Trump start replenishing it what
happened during those three years Kaylee
if it was so bare when Barack Obama left
I did talk to secretary azar a little
bit about this yesterday and one of the
things secretary azar said to me is you
know when we got to the federal
government we were on the brink of we
were in very hostile confrontations with
several powers because of the Obama
administration's foreign policy and
there were real bioterrorism threats and
that was the immediate threat that the
administration focused on in terms of
the stockpile and immediately when it
became clear a pandemic was the the
concern over bioterrorism she means two
months ago quickly as humanly possible
right and filled the empty so remember
three years they didn't fill the empty
cupboards February March they start to
fill them understand that that's what
she's saying primary this
administration's effort was on the
stockpile that we've shipped 766
ventilators overseas to our partners
because no one here has died for lack of
a ventilators so we've done so well and
overperformed so much we can say that
we've committed over 15,000 ventilators
to 40 countries by the end of July
because that is American ingenuity that
is the government of president comment
of this government and the private
sector yeah
switching gears for just a moment also
does interview with Maria Bartiromo the
other day the president suggested people
should be jailed for what he said
earlier in the week was a very obvious
crime you're an attorney and the
president spokesperson perhaps you could
lay out the elements what is the press
crime what crime was committed and in
what way
I assume you're referring to the Obama
administration and the unmasking and
vomiting what is it what are the
elements of that crime yeah and I'm
really glad you asked because there
hasn't been a lot of journalistic
curiosity on this front and I'm very
glad that you asked this question look
there were a number of questions raised
by the actions of the Obama
administration the steel dossier funded
by the Democratic National Committee the
opposition political party to the
president was used to attain FISA
warrants to listen in on conversations
of people within the Trump campaign
there was the unmasking the identity of
Michael Flynn and we know that in a
January fifth meeting in the Oval Office
with President Obama Sally Yates from
the Department of Justice learned about
the unmasking not from the Department of
Justice or the FBI she learned about it
from President Obama and was stunned and
can barely process what she was hearing
at what's the crime case done of his
knowledge of that we know that there was
a lot of wrongdoing in the case of
Michael Flynn the FBI notes for instance
that said should we get him to lie as
they pontificated their strategy we know
that the idea already lied at the time
it was just a matter of strategy for an
interrogation and the question is what
is the crime what's the crime Kaley the
press of his identity and violation of
his Fourth Amendment rights these are
very serious questions they've been
ignored by the media for far too long
and I'm very glad that I think that is
the second question that I have fielded
on Lieutenant General Michael Flynn
because justice does matter those
questions what's the crime what's the
crime I heard you mention one thing you
said was Krim
and that was what no 1 thing that I've
said that was criminal the leaking of
his name and the very real questions
that have been raised but if you want to
start talking about wrongdoing the
administration happy to go through
McCabe leaking to the Wall Street
Journal and then lying about it happy to
talk about James clapper lying before
Congress saying the NSA does not monitor
phone calls that was in an act Wow this
is this is stunning why John Brennan
telling Congress that the bogus steel
dossier played no role in the Russia
probe when in fact we know it did and
was the basis of it that was perjury
charge him with perjury I mean good
charged him with perjury if that's what
you believe he did but what was the
Obama crime then many other real
questions that I hope you all will
pursue I never said that those are your
words not mine but perhaps you should
look into it and get me some answers
that is after all the job that is after
all the job of reporters to answer the
very questions that I've laid out and I
hope you guys will take the time to do
it and and I also find it interesting oh
she's talking about fabrication of
crimes we can litigate that case pretty
publicly with James clapper what's the
Obama crime Caylee what's the Obama
crime pails and that Watergate paled in
comparison we can talk about Eric's well
well lying and saying President Trump
was working on behalf of the Russians we
can talk about Hakeem Jeffries crying
and saying the president was a Russian
ask that we can talk about shift saying
there was ample evidence of collusion
and plain sight brought in fact there
was not we can talk about Mark Warner
which there's enormous amounts of
evidence of collusion we can talk about
a CNN historian who said there was a
smell of treason and the Trump CNN
historian might have been wrong on the
air now what's the Obama crime talked
about collusion and there was none and
it was a huge injustice not just to this
administration what's the American
people who deserve truth not the
alleging of absolutely false allegations
against this president yes thank you
it's like your sanity exactly sorry one
second I can't really so I'll get to you
next go ahead francis pushback by a
comment by the CEO of Santa Fe that the
United States would be first in line for
a vaccine if that firm develops because
of initial funding by Barda the scene
does the administration think that the
United States should receive the first
doses as Santa Fe does discover that
vaccine I don't have I haven't spoken to
the president about that so I don't have
any announcements on that front but yes
back there and then thank you clearly
two brief questions first a follow-up to
Steve's question regarding China 48
hours ago the federal retirement thrift
Investment Board followed the
president's suggestion and cut off any
investment of federal pensions for
civilian and military workers into China
on their markets therefore cutting off
funds that would be invested in
state-run companies now will the
president now urge private sector
businesses and I think of Blackrock
which is invested in a hundred and
thirty seven Chinese companies to follow
this example and get out of investing in
China well I can't give any information
about what the president will or will
not do next but it's a really important
topic and I would just say that the
president's decisive move to halt plans
for investing TSP funds into Chinese
companies was the right call it protects
our military federal employees from
risky investments and avoids funding
Chinese defense contractors and this
action halts plans to invest military
Federal Employees Retirement funds of
4.5 billion in Chinese equities so it
was an important move by the president
but in terms of future action on this
front I would leave that to the
president
other question was in Turkey recently
there's been taught that the president
heard on
like the assistance of President Trump
with the currency in Turkey which is in
very bad condition right will there be
any US support of the Turkish currency
or does he think mr. Herr Diwan should
apply for an IMF loan yeah I don't have
any information on that but future
actions with regard to Turkish currency
yes what you call the bombing game is he
willing to declassify the transcript
that general Flint's call the third date
his lack so everyone can see what was
said I've not asked him that what I know
that he would like to see right now is
the lost 302 apparently lost 302 we know
a 302 is a summary of an interview that
the FBI did with Michael Flynn that has
apparently gone missing so we would
really be quite curious to see what
transpired in that 302 after the FBI
Pontic pontificated quote getting Flynn
to lies that they could get him fired or
prosecuted normal talks occurring and
the White House supports more aid to
state and local government as
so the president has said that he would
talk about state and local aid but it
cannot become a pretext for bailing out
blue states that have gotten to
themselves gotten themselves into
financial trouble so while he's open to
discussing it he has no immediate plans
to move forward with the phase four he
said something he's looking at somebody
wants to take some time to consider what
should be in it
um the Pelosi bill has been entirely
unacceptable for instance one of the
things that I found really funny in her
bill mom what she requires that the
president appoint a medical supply
response coordinator who would serve at
the point as the point of contact for
the healthcare system supply chain
officials and states on medical supplies
I don't know if speaker Pelosi has just
not been a paying attention while she's
been out in California we've been here
working but I happen to be sitting by
this so-called medical supply response
coordinator on Air Force One yesterday
he's been around for quite some time
his name is Adam is Admiral pull ups
check so pelagic is coordinating this
and perhaps she she doesn't know that
because Admiral P has been doing this
for quite some time but that's just an
example of how quite odd the Pelosi bill
is packed full of liberal wish list like
some liberal get direct payments because
they're not looking at Social Security
numbers to verify that taxpayer dollars
are going on taxpayers so elements like
that are non-starters and there's just
luckily curious elements that really
suggest if the speaker is even paying
attention Chanel so going back to you
here is that the
Pelosi presented it sedation for a vote
and you have members of her own party
coming in and saying this is Washington
politics at its worst does the White
House get a sense that members of the
Democratic Party are starting to grow
less confident in directly but I have
seen some of the comments you're talking
about and it certainly would suggest
that I mean we're in the middle of a
pandemic and what is Nancy Pelosi doing
that woman voiding the crisis and
pushing for mass mail and voting even
though we know it's more susceptible to
voting fraud I mean we're in the middle
of a pandemic and this is what she's
interested in pushing instead of talking
about real measures like the payroll tax
which would be a tax break for low and
middle income Americans she's injured
she's interested in removing the
threshold for state and local tax
deductions which would essentially be a
huge win for billionaires in California
and New York so it's really interesting
right now that you have the party that
says they're for working Americans
saying let's remove this state and local
tax a threshold so that millionaires and
billionaires get big payouts in states
like California and New York and you
have the Republican Party and the party
of President Trump saying let's lower
the payroll tax so that low-income
Americans who pay more payroll taxes yes
and underfund Social Security and
Medicare through the end of the year is
what she won't mention about that
proposal
was there at any point any knowledge
that when the transition between the
Obama administration into the Trump
administration did anybody from the
Trump the Obama team briefed the Obama
administration administration about your
position at one point the PBE moths went
down to below two percent what the
national need was did anybody from the
Obama administration warned the trumpet
he had three years to replenish
not to my knowledge to my knowledge the
two things President Obama warned about
our North Korea and Michael Flynn what I
do know is this the Obama administration
wasn't throwing ventilators into the
stock pile they were unmasking
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn opening
days of their administration yes the
president has said that that should be a
part of the back stimulus bill but he's
also indicated that there are
discussions for more direct payments so
does he favor one or the other or does
he think you can do both
he hasn't indicated that anything is a
condition or starter or a non-starter
he's floated some ideas that he'd like
to see in a phase four I mean at this
point I think he's looking closely at
what we need to spend if a phase four
does occur on these are taxpayer dollars
he wants to move forward wisely but I
haven't heard of any particular thing
being a condition and a starter or a
non-starter other than the fact that the
so-called heroes act on is certainly a
non-starter yes thank you Kevin
in a previous life as a our law student
and
fifteen you were vocally against the US
Supreme Court's decision in favor of
same-sex marriage bond arguments for
article palabra you think that's
consistent with the president's views
look um you know I'm not up here to give
my personal views on anything what I'd
say is that I'm very proud of this
administration which has been fair and
equitable and just to all Americans and
open to all Americans as he should be I
think our views are entirely consistent
and I'm not up here to give my views on
a Supreme Court case for many years ago
he's fine with the decision it considers
a matter yeah I stand behind the
president I stand by in his views I'm
here to represent the president and not
to pontificate about Supreme Court cases
from long ago yes quickly and I'm just
to follow up there's an any day now
there's going to be another decision
from the Supreme Court related to LGBTQ
rights and while there are LGBT federal
civil rights law covers LGBTQ people is
the administration doing any sort of a
contingency planning for that decision
okay again I'm not going to get ahead of
the Supreme Court or give a Supreme
Court case projection or outcome it's
not my position to do that
so I have no information for you on that
at this time yes
president Trump has just tweeted that US
is going to donate ventilators to India
do you know how many numbers of
ventilators u.s. is donating to India I
don't know that but president just
extolled our great relationship with
India India has been a great partner to
us for quite some time and I'm
encouraged here about the ventilators to
India it's one of the several countries
I noted that will be getting ventilators
because you know this president has done
so well on ventilators a hundred
thousand and a hundred days that we are
able to repurpose them and send them
around the world and John pew research
center said that most of the
tend to Tony a vote for the Democrats
since President had met in outreach
shooting intimate friends comment the
last four years I didn't hear the first
part of your question can you say that
again so they had they said key come out
with a report we said that most of the
Indian Americans mostly vote for the
Democrats not the Republicans do you
agree with the assessment well that
would be a question for the campaign so
I'd refer you to the campaign on that
Pew poll yes the president has said
before Kayla that he would like to see a
hundred million doses of a viable
vaccine by the fall and three hundred
million by January today he didn't
mention a hundred million by the fall
but he did mention hopefully getting a
vaccine by the new year is he tempering
expectations of what might be possible
no she's still hoping for a hundred
million doses by the fall now this
president is not tempering expectations
in fact I think we should be very
encouraged about what we heard today
from dr. Salah we that the early data
from clinical trials for coronavirus
vaccine data makes him confident that we
will have a vaccine by the end of 2020
operation warp-speed
is a great new innovative operation that
i think it's hard to even take that name
seriously dr. salah we said in short
order and consultation he's doing this
of course with the four-star general
general pronoun is his name but there
might be a great effort and i think by
the fall we will see one as has been
predicted this president wants to see
one process as fast as humanly possible
and i would note that he got us into
Phase one clinical trial faster than dr.
Faust yet ever Trump didn't do anything
on that understand Trump did nothing on
that president has really put the fire
under the private sector and under the
FDA to get ninety two emergency use
authorization for testing get to phase 1
clinical trial faster than ever before
and we can thank President Trump for
being at the helm of Oliver actually you
know I think I got like two questions
for me to do so I enjoyed speaking with
you all have a great weekend
and I like your pink blazer Caitlyn
oh my god what a complete and total mess
Wow Wow
I mean just these these are getting more
and more dystopian and the degree of
dishonesty and fart the farcical nature
of these is crazy listen let me make
sure that everybody who signed up on my
web site gets a thank you that includes
will Dudley melody la Cuesta as well as
Michael cannon and Aiden O'Malley huge
thank you to Dave Perry and Joel Adams
really really appreciate everybody
supported join pakman.com we have sort
of heard it all at this point and for me
so you know let's focus in just on one
really big area of deception here on the
one hand Trump insists the cupboards
were bare the cupboards were bare the
cupboards were bare because of Barack
Obama when Kayleigh is really asked well
when did Trump start replenishing PPE
she says as soon as it was clear a
pandemic was what we were going to have
to deal with Obama left in January 2017
Trump claims he learned about the
pandemic in a serious manner in January
of 2020 February of 2020 that's
admitting that for three years the
cupboards were not replenished why not
how did Trump the manager in chief and
the genius business person wait three
years before he started replenishing
that cupboard it doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense and it is just
another one of these lies thank you for
joining me I'll be back with another
stream I'm sure and clips publishing all
throughout the weekend appreciate
everybody joining me on Twitter twitch
YouTube and Facebook see you soon
you